with the victories for the marijuana
legalization initiatives in Colorado and
Washington on Election Day 2012 it
really presents the White House and the
Attorney General with a dilemma because
on the one hand they and their law
enforcement officials federal law
enforcement officials you know can point
out and have repeatedly said it's all
illegal under federal law regardless of
what the states do it's still illegal
under federal law to possess by you sell
grow all illegal that's it but as we saw
with medical marijuana which began to be
legalized back in the mid-90s and is now
legal in 18 states and Washington DC
it's not so simple and what we see is
that the federal government has allowed
various states to set up their own
systems to regulate medical marijuana
some places are interfering some places
they're letting it be you know what
Obama said when he ran for president the
first time and what he and the Justice
Department made good on in the first
year back in 2009 was to say that if
medical marijuana producers dispensaries
are operating legally and transparently
under state law it will not be a federal
law enforcement priority so the federal
policy has been very mixed with some of
the federal US Attorney's being very
aggressive in places like Montana in
California and trying to shit ever be
down and other states like New Mexico or
Maine or other parts of New England
really holding back right and then you
look at a place like Colorado which
legalized medical marijuana back in two
thousand and then adopted a statewide
regulatory approach a few years ago
through the legislature signed by the
governor and even there you have
hundreds of dispensaries operating above
ground being taxed regulated law
enforcement government officials oversee
them there's a medical marijuana
Enforcement Division so you have in
Colorado a very good model for
regulating above-ground marijuana and
you have in Washington State and some
other states a very good model for
regulating alcohol above ground so I'm
very curious to see what the White House
and the Justice Department do you know
two years ago when the marijuana
legalization issue was on the ballot in
California in 2010 a month before the
election Holder the Attorney General
said to California
you better watch out because if you do
this the feds are not going to allow
this this time in 2012 holder did not
say a word notwithstanding the fact that
all the former heads of the DEA and the
former heads of the drug czars office
all banding together appealing him but I
think what happened was the White House
and other people in those states looked
at the polling they saw for example
Colorado was a swing state they saw this
issue is very popular especially with
young voters and independence who could
be swing voters in this election and
they decided the better course of action
was not to say anything you also have
the fact that the governor's and
attorneys general of these two states
Colorado Washington are saying look we
want to implement the will of the people
in good faith I mean you have the fact
that the Colorado legalization
initiative got more votes on election
day that Obama did and in Washington
state the initiative got more votes than
either of the candidates who became or
got elected governor and attorney
general I you have and all of them are
saying they want to implement these
initiatives in good faith you also have
the fact that Obama has in his private
discussions with people about drug
policy both with foreign presidents and
with wealthy Democratic donors and key
political people all of whom I've spoken
with they all say that Obama and Biden
are indicating a willingness to move in
a somewhat new direction you have the
Washington Post which is always
editorialized sort of much more
sympathetic to the drug war than many
other leading papers but just recently
saying that the Fed should give Colorado
and Washington a chance to implement
these things so I won't go so far as to
say I'm optimistic about what the feds
are going to do but I'd say there's a
lot of good reasons why the feds might
give this a chance to be implemented
correctly and keep in mind nobody needs
to do anything right away you know these
initiatives enter into force in the next
few in december early december i think
and at that point it'll be legal to
possess up to an ounce of marijuana in
both states and legal to grow up to six
plants in the privacy of your home in
Colorado but the provisions that
authorize the state government to set up
a regulatory system those don't kick in
in colorado till july first and in
washington state till december of 2013
so both states have
I'm and the feds are able to take a
wait-and-see approach my hope is that's
what they'll do